se ha ocasionado un fuerte columnas de
humo salen del centro femenino de
adaptación social una penitenciaría
cerca de la ciudad Tegucigalpa
imágenes de una de las peores tragedias
carcelarias en la historia de Honduras
decenas de reclusas murieron luego de
una aparente motín organizado por
pandillas rivales las autoridades
anunciaron que están investigando lo
sucedido y culpan al crimen organizado
el pueblo
honduretón tendencia que no
va a emitir bajo ningún punto el ataque
o el Sabotaje contra las acciones que se
han emprendido hacia y dirigidas la
criminalidad organizada la criminalidad
organizada que ha secuestrado el sistema
penitenciario de este país sin embargo
en las calles hay malestares en las
autoridades a las que culpan del hecho
por no controlar de forma apropiada el
ingreso de armas al penal por parte de
las pandillas entonces discutiblemente
aquí no hay que reposar nada más que el
instituto y más que el estado porque yo
no responsables de guardar la seguridad
de los privados de libertad familiares
de las víctimas piden justicia como
abuela que soy Necesito saber el nombre
de mi nieta si está viva o ya está
muerta por qué porque no sé nada en eso
únicamente nosotros es lo que queremos
queremos justicia y queremos que nos den
el nombre de cada uno de nuestros
familiares Este no es el primer
incidente mortal en las cárceles de
Honduras un país que tiene una de las
tasas nacionales de homicidios más altas
del mundo